not a good appearance for the American
president at the NATO summit in Europe
let's start with Emmanuel macron who is
of course the newly elected president of
France decisively defeated right-wing
candidate marine lepen and he is very
decisively making himself heard and seen
on the world stage really making our
president look bad in a number of ways
he took office couple weeks ago
he's already speaking out about sort of
insightful observation he's made about
American president Donald Trump he gave
an interview to a French newspaper over
the weekend and Makran pointed out that
when it comes to diplomacy Donald Trump
basically sees his relationships with
foreign leaders in terms of who has the
most power and we see this in what he
says we see it in his attempts to do
certain types of handshakes which
believe me we're going to get to the
handshakes on today's show and macron
compared Trump to other authoritarian
heads of state Russian President
Vladimir Putin turkish president air
doan who are also diplomatically
arrogant to say the least
you'll recall that Emmanuel macron
campaign was hacked
during the French election presumably it
appears by Russian actors and the Krong
seems to want to have more integrity
than what we've seen from Trump and
actually challenged that behavior and
it's really funny how among some
right-wing circles in the United States
France has been framed over the last 15
years as weak as feminized as those
feminized French men France now has a
president that is the one dominating the
dialogue with respect to characters like
Donald Trump and dominating the
handshakes as well but again we'll get
to that I don't want to get ahead of
myself on the handshakes here is French
president Emmanuel macron in the journal
du demage where he said quote Donald
Trump the Turkish president or the
Russian president Seve relationships in
terms of a balance of power that doesn't
bother me I don't believe in diplomacy
by public abuse but in my bilateral
dialogues I won't let anything pass and
he makes a good point which is although
Trump probably sees diplomacy in the
same way that Putin and air Dewan do too
err Dewan are much better at it than is
Donald Trump and and we're seeing that
just about every day uh uh Makran was
asked about how he was something about
that tense handshake that he had with
Donald Trump at the NATO summit in
Brussels and indeed this was a moment
where you know Trump is famous for his
aggressive domineering handshakes and
we're showing you here what it looked
like when Donald Trump shook hands with
Emmanuel macron wherever Trump goes he
tries to make himself seem dominant over
whoever he's shaking hands with at the
NATO meeting French president Makran
would not have that and when they were
shaking hands it was very clear that
Makran wanted to send a message to trump
that he was not going to be a pushover
when it comes out only the handshakes
but also to relations between the US and
France here is their moment
so as you watch here our TV audience
seeing a long confident handshake
squashing Donald Trump tiny hand and
looking very satisfied while doing so
Trump tries to pull away Makran doesn't
let him I love it right Donald Trump
cooked by Makran number one but Pat
number two we're going to get to in a
second and it's even worse Makran
actually said this was deliberate he was
asked about the entire handshake thing
and he again said in the journal du
dimanche
quote my handshake with him it wasn't
innocent it's not the be-all and the
end-all of a policy but it was a moment
of truth
so already Pat Trump's games not working
with McCrone well obviously whoever has
the most domineering handshake has a
superior country obviously Trump was
able to beat out Japanese leader Shinzo
Abe a yes but of course he lost the
battle to tajikistan president yes it's
always an ongoing battle that was just
unbelievable and and there's we could do
an entire show on handshakes but we're
not going to do that right now okay so
anyway you know Emmanuel macron not not
the progressive be-all-end-all to use
his phrase but by any means but it's we
should be glad that it was a manual
macron sitting in this chair and not
marine lepen
who would have been singing Donald
Trump's praises but here's the real
moment where Trump is just totally
cooked by macron and is this so funny
because all right I say this I'm joking
around right the alt-right talks about
this person's akak that person's a [ __ ]
there's no moment of greater cucking on
the international diplomatic stage than
what I'm about to play for you at the
NATO summit Emmanuel macron walking
towards a group of world leaders
including Donald Trump and it appears as
though McCrone is going right for Trump
Trump is ready because he's going to be
the first person to be greeted by
Emmanuel macron the big guy on campus
and then McCrone swerves over and he
hugs and kisses German Chancellor Angela
Merkel shakes another hand looks like
he's moving towards Trump but then oh oh
he's back through the other side and it
is not Trump Trump made to wait his turn
and you see Trump trying to do the pull
in handshake there
and it's too late it's too late because
he's been cut and it is this is stunning
and then Donald Trump like the little
kid at the sandbox that used to be the
bully but now everybody else is saying
we don't really need the bully we can do
our own thing it's amazing because you
can tell that these other world leaders
are studying this of course you had that
domineering handshake with Neil Gorsuch
yesterday tricity so people like Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau study it and
they know how to react when you make
that aggressive handshake so Trudeau
grabs the shoulder you have other real
world leaders pushing and pulling all
the states become a sort of game and
it's a game that Donald Trump actually
started and it completely I mean just
embarrassingly and this is only the
visual aspect I actually want to get now
to the real diplomatic embarrassment of
Trump at NATO